if you and I started this podcast and we
were like okay you know hey that was
pretty cool and then we invited on uh
somebody that was in charge of pet uh
animals uh veterinarian right and then
we were like okay hey that was cool and
the veterinarian was cool to talk to so
then all of a sudden we're like hey
let's do the next one in the
veterinarian's shop and we can hopefully
get some of these animals that are up
for adoption we can get them adopted
right and so a lot cool and then all of
a sudden we look up in two years and
we're running an adoption agency for
pets I got nothing against pets I want I
don't want dogs to get put down from the
pound
but
if my main effort in life was helping
stray dogs get uh adopted again that's a
great effort but it wouldn't be what I
would want to concentrate on